تستمر حرب فلاديمير بوتين في أوكرانيا في
الامتداد إلى الأراضي الروسية، ويلقي
المسؤولون في روسيا الآن اللوم على أوكرانيا
في هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار والقصف في
عدة مناطق اليوم، ويتضمن ذلك
الخريطة التي يمكنك رؤيتها تبرز
بلغراد القريبة كما ترون
بالقرب من الحدود تظهر سيارة أجرة  أن تكون في
ارتفاع هناك منذ أن ادعت مجموعة من
المواطنين الروس المتحالفين مع أوكرانيا أنها
شنت هجومًا على
بلادهم قبل أكثر
من أسبوع بقليل. ظلت أوكرانيا هادئة إلى حد كبير
بشأن هذه الهجمات دون أن
تعلن مسؤوليتها المباشرة ولكن في
أعلى السن  إلى الرئيس الأوكراني يقول إن
أبواب الحرب قد فتحت على
الأراضي الروسية، فلننتقل مباشرة إلى CNN
sankali في harkid و Sam بالأمس في
البرنامج، لقد أخبرتني أن هذه
الهجمات عبر الحدود
أصبحت الآن أعتقد أنه من العدل أن نقول
أكثر منهجية  من الممكن أن نشهد
مرحلة جديدة في هذه الحرب، ما الذي
يمكن أن يعنيه هذا؟ ما هي المخاطر التي تراها
هنا؟
حسنًا، أعتقد أن المخاطر التي قيمها
فلاديمير بوتين ليست
عالية جدًا حقًا، وهي بالضبط
النتائج من حيث المصطلحات  من
وجهة النظر الأوكرانية التي يريدون أن يروا
رد فعل الكرملين
حيث يتعين على فلاديمير بوتين أن يذهب إلى
التلفزيون الحكومي وفي مؤتمر ليخبر
شعبه ألا يقلقوا من أنه
يتعين على الحكومة تثبيت
السفينة.  ما قاله
إنه متحف
اليوم سوف نتعامل مع نفس القضايا
فيما يتعلق بضمان أمن
روسيا في هذه الحالة الأمن السياسي الداخلي مع
الأخذ في الاعتبار الجهود
التي لا يزال منتقدونا يبذلونها
ويكثفونها من أجل إثارة
الوضع في الداخل  إن
إثارة الوضع داخل
روسيا الآن هو على وجه التحديد جدول أعمال هاتين
المجموعتين من المنشقين الروس الذين
تدعمهم أوكرانيا وتسليحهم أوكرانيا
ويسافرون في المركبات الموردة من أوكرانيا، كما
يقولون، ولديهم أيضًا مصادر تمويل خاصة بهم وبالطبع
الهجمات المستمرة التي  لقد رأينا فيما
يتعلق بهجوم الطائرات بدون طيار منذ تحدثنا
بالأمس، فقد وقع هجوم آخر بطائرات بدون طيار
على بلدة سمولينسك أه في
مقاطعة سمولينس على بعد مسافة طويلة
شمال الحدود الأوكرانية وفوق كل
ذلك تستمر الهجمات في بلغارد
مع  قال الحاكم هناك إنه تم
إجلاء ألفين ونصف شخص من القرى المحيطة وكان
يقوم ببث مباشر ليكتب محاولًا
طمأنة سكانه وأثناء
مشاهدة هذا البث المباشر، رأيت
القليل من الأسباب المحتملة وراء كون هذا
أيضًا سببًا  حملة إلكترونية تتضمن الكثير من
الأسئلة الزائفة والغريبة إلى حد ما التي يتم
طرحها عليه بوضوح من قبل الأشخاص الذين يحاولون
تقويض اكتشاف قدرته على تهدئة
أعصاب الشعب الروسي بالقرب من
الحدود مع أوكرانيا.
أعذر ليزا هذا، أعني أنني رأيت تقارير
اليوم وأنا أعلم.  لقد خرجت من
الرافعة الشرقية الشرقية وأنت قادم من
الروس هنا يا سام بشأن هجوم
شنته الوحدات الشيشانية، هل هذه إحدى تلك
القصص التي ستخبرني بها أننا
بحاجة إلى الحذر من
أه حسنًا أنا والروس  أعتقد أن
الأوكرانيين متفقون على أن أه القوات الخاصة الشيشانية قد تم
نقلها إلى
ساحة المعركة ليس بعيدًا عن أنه من
المفترض أن يكون هناك تهدئة
مستمرة الآن تقريبًا أو تنتهي
بشكل أو بآخر بين
مجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر والقوات الروسية النظامية للرجبي
إنها أيضًا مرة أخرى
تقارير لا يمكن التحقق منها واردة من
بلغارد تفيد بأنه ربما تم
نقل القوات الخاصة الروسية إلى هناك،
والاقتراح الذي قدمه الأوكرانيون هو
أنه تم نقلهم من المسرح
في الشرق ولكن مرة أخرى أنت على حق يا عيسى،
يجب أن نأخذ أي شيء
يقول الأوكرانيون عما يفعله الروس ما
لم يكن لديهم
دليل مباشر مع قليل من الملح